[Musik]
wir sind heute abend hier um danke zu
sagen dann kann die ganzen großspender
dank an die menschen die die ein herz
für kinder schon seit so vielen jahren
unterstützt und eben spenden einsammeln
denn gerade in der heutigen zeit in der
der ukraine ein krieg herrscht ist so
besonders wichtig auch an die kinder zu
denken und deswegen stoßen heute auch
auf die kinder an den wir bereits
geholfen haben und den wir auch in
zukunft helfen werden haben jetzt ja
gehört es gibt mittlerweile sechs
millionen euro spenden für die kinder
und keine was macht das hört
[Musik]
ich finde wir müssen einfach die
verantwortlichkeit nehmen für unsere
kinder ich mir selber mutter und
natürlich ist man dann noch extra
bewusst was es ist wenn ein kind leidet
ein kind in armut leben wo man geht mir
geschichten
man schmeckt oder macht wieder auf das
unheimlich kompliziert weil es auch
nicht weit weg ist manches leid man
hofft auf besserung aber leider gottes
kommen täglich keine positive nachricht
er heute hier am abend weiter habe die
spendentrommel zu
warum ist es so wichtig dass wir auch
geldspenden also wie kann man mit geld
diesen kindern helfen mal beschreiben
und damit geld ist schwer vereinigen
[Musik]
deswegen ist natürlich nicht nur
sachspenden sich die sonne ist wie in
meinem leben kamen mit geld dafür
bewegen und zwar sehr viel gutes und
weltweit ist die muss
so eine gewisse gerechtigkeit ist
einfach schön
organisation wie ein herz für kinder
auch wirklich
man merkt vor allen beteiligten die sind
mit jeder faser ihres herzens dabei und
wir unterstützen das wo wir nur können
[Musik]
durch nicht ganz herzlich bedanken über
einen kleinen und großen spendern die
unsere arbeit überhaupt erst möglich
machen für die ukraine sind seit
ausbruch des krieges mehr als sechs
millionen euro zusammengekommen
zusätzlich zu dem vielen geld was in der
großen spendengala im dezember gespendet
wurde und dafür kann ich mich nur von
herzen bedanken denn jeder cent dieses
geldes kommt bei kindern an die es
wirklich brauchen das können wir
natürlich nur bestätigen und deswegen
sagen wir auch weiterhin spendet spendet
spendet denn das geld kommt an das geld
kommt an für die kleinsten die es
wirklich am nötigsten brauchen
[Musik]